the nominees for the 2015 game awards
have been announced with the witcher 3
wild hunt leading the way with seven
total nominations including a nod for
overall game of the year others
nominated for the top award include
fallout 4 blood-borne metal gear solid 5
the phantom pain and Super Mario maker
the witcher 3 also earned nominations
for best narrative best art direction
best score and soundtrack best
performance and best role playing game
the game's developer CD Projekt RED was
nominated for developer of the year
produced by games media veteran Jeff
Keeley and partnership with a variety of
game publishers and sponsored in part by
Verizon the 2015 Game Awards air on
Thursday December third starting at 6pm
pacific daylight time these nominations
were chosen by a jury of 32
international media members including a
representative from GameSpot to be
considered games needed to have been
commercially released by November 24th
we'll have the full rundown of winners
on December third I don't know about you
but my fingers are crossed for
blood-borne for a full list of nominees
head over to GameSpot's